I'll give you a bit more detail
you have to explode expression with the
hand so my hand is at right angles
really
right if it's not a right angles and
it's sort of like halfway there I've
started closing up this Gap here
so
what happens is his wrist doesn't turn
all the way over it stays uh if I had a
Joe it would be like at that angle
I need it
parallel is it parallel flat I need it
this way so the thumb can go in there
now now it might seem a small thing but
if I only turn it a little bit my thumb
gets a grip
but it never gets at the flat the flat
can't of the thumb can't get on it
I get a bit there but the thumb now has
to bend to get there if I turn it I just
put the thumb in and it fits can you all
see that
okay
that's what makes it strong
so you've got to crank it round
you've got to crank that round until
that thumb
has got that family
because what we're going to do is we're
not going to just do she and Aggie and
this thumb is going to be really
important to where where it's placed
when we get doing higher forms like Yoko
mnuchi and that you're going to be
finding it's really difficult to get
that Thumb in in time
because your other hand gets busy to to
come in right so so we're starting off
with a small one but this isn't turned
enough look so I've got to crank it
as hard as I can crank it I need to
crank it
okay
so please you know this is why you've
come all this distance this is why
you've paid your money this is why
you're taking time out of your life
it won't be just one technique you get
today if you understand
oh I want my style
you know if you understand one point it
goes to many points but even with all my
trying I might not get through to you
today but perhaps John Nick Richard Doug
you know somebody will they'll go Carl
why didn't I say that all those years
ago
and that was exactly the same with me
with cider Sensei even though he was to
me the best out there
I didn't get it I got my women Aggie off
Yamada Sensi I got my up brightness off
tubercency
so I stole what I needed because I
couldn't see it uh within my own teacher
right but this
to me is our senses Aikido but
cytosensis in my image
crank it over okay come on
[Music]